this is sarita she's a cotton top
tamarin
one of the smallest primates in the
world
after years of being poached and
captured in the wild the already
endangered cotton top now faces the
rapid destruction of its habitat
[Music]
cotton tops are native to south america
and can only be found in a limited
forested area of northwest columbia they
make their homes in trees there and
enjoy a diet of fruits and insects
although exceedingly rare in the wild
cotton tops are recognizable by the
shock of white hair on their heads these
primates are social creatures they live
in hierarchical family groups led by a
dominant pair of mating cotton tops and
the pair's offspring are raised
communally by the group
for many years their numbers were
decimated by the illegal pet trade and
their capture for biomedical research
but today deforestation is the main
culprit behind their dwindling numbers
their wild population has shrunk by 80
over the past three generations they're
holding on by the tips of their claws
this is the cottontop tamarind
you